I majored in theater at Carnegie Mellon
University and I and I like to say
really I majored in empathy empathy
empathy study of theater great classic
scripts going to see theater it helps
people learn empathy and empathy it has
to do with understanding what people
other people are doing why they're doing
it how they're doing it what do you do
when they do it a beautiful opportunity
to understand our humanities whether you
get the part you want and then you have
to make the part that you got into
something special
empathetic action to to do a play and to
read someone else's words the acts of
making theater together is a really
community building experience it
literally helps you teach and train your
brain and your heart to feel for others
to learn from others experiences and I
think in our world today that's just it
couldn't be more important